we're going to begin with the threat of
nuclear war a comment from President
Biden reacting to threats from Russia's
president on the use of so-called
tactical nuclear weapons in Ukraine Mr
Biden said he does not think that
Vladimir Putin is joking comments came
last night at a fundraiser in New York
where Mr Biden said we have not faced
the prospect of Armageddon since Kennedy
and the Cuban Missile Crisis he added I
don't think there is any such thing as
the ability to use a tactical nuclear
weapon and not end up with Armageddon
this comes at a time when Ukraine's Army
appears to be weakening Russia's
military position and that's generating
fears about what exactly the Russian
leader will do to win the war that he
started in February Charlie dagada is in
Ukraine for us once again Charlie good
morning
good morning to you Tony we've been to
the front lines in liberated cities but
you don't have to go that far to see the
destruction that Russia is capable of as
we witness for ourselves in zapparesia
foreign
scrambled in a desperate search for
those who survived the missile strike at
times finding those who did not we
arrived to find firefighters dousing a
mountain of Twisted Metal and debris war
crimes investigators looking through the
rubble local residents in disbelief
several hours after the rocket attack
and the building is still smoldering
this is no longer a rescue operation
this is a building smack dab in the
middle of zaparisia
and while the city is firmly under
Ukrainian control it's the regional
capital of one of the areas President
Putin illegally annexed just days ago
Elena got a 5 a.m phone call from her 70
year old mother saying she was trapped
beneath the rubble is she going to be
okay was she injured in New York she has
broken ribs a lung contusion and a
broken leg she said but she is alive are
you okay you seem very composed were you
not terrified are you not angry already
angry
it's not possible in our time it's not
possible
and our country
we need help
lying on the pavement three of at least
11 people killed here
it's in victims of President Putin's
senseless war that had nothing to do
with it
it's the second major missile attack
targeting residents in zapparesia within
a week last Friday we saw the aftermath
of a strike on a civilian Convoy that
killed at least 30 people
Battlefield commanders tell us Russian
forces are in complete disarray their
retaliation launching long-range weapons
into residential areas spreading Terror
what Russia can't capture it seeks to
destroy
one reason for the recent success
according to a British intelligence
report today ukrainians have captured so
many Russian tanks at least 440 it's
estimated that roughly half of the tank
Fleet now consists of Russian tanks Dana
all right Charlie dagada in Ukraine
thank you